Whether you're waiting for an exam, about
to start an important presentation or at the
start of a race, we've all experienced nervousness.
But why do we get nervous, and could looking
at professional athletes help us understand
how to effectively cope with it?
In stressful situations, your brain sends
a signal from the pituitary gland all the
way to the kidneys where your adrenal gland
resides. And this is where adrenaline is released.
You've felt it before -- the rapid heart rate,
dilating pupils and increased circulation
in your muscles. It's all part of the "fight
or flight" response which developed in our
evolutionary history to help us survive. But
this response isn't all or nothing -- there
are degrees of reaction, according to the
perceived threat or importance you attach
to the outcome. So something like an interview,
which presents a challenge, stimulates the
same biological reaction that a threat to
your life does -- just to a smaller degree.
Feel those nervous butterflies in your stomach?
This is because adrenaline helps redirect
blood and energy to the most important parts
of your body during stress, like the heart
and muscles, and away from your digestive
system causing the blood vessels to close
around your stomach leading to that tingling
sensation.
So, how do professional athletes handle the
stress and nerves?
The concept of 'mental imagery' is a widely
used method in popular sport. With 'Cognitive
Specific' imagery, an athlete simply imagines
themselves practicing a technique or skill
before competing or training. And while it
may sound crazy, this actually stimulates
the relevant neurons in the brain, and has
been shown to enhance the specific skill.
'Motivational Specific' imagery on the other
hand encourages athletes to recall the feeling
of winning an event or beating a competitor
as a motivational tool. Finally, "Motivational
General-Mastery" is commonly used by athletes
to feel more confident. Again, by simply imagining
themselves as focused, tough and having positive
thoughts prior to competition, athletes are
able to improve performance and overcome nerves.
Confidence, in particular, is a consistent
factor that distinguishes successful athletes
from others, and a major focus for professional
coaches.
So, next time you feel those nerves kick in,
try preparing like an Olympian would! What
are
you waiting for? On your mark, get set, GO!
Don't forget: we have a new video out every day during the Olympics.
Can't wait? Our amazing partners at the CBC already have five of the videos up now for you to binge on.
Just head to cbc.ca/olympics/ScienceSays to watch them before anyone else. Link in the description.
But we also want to know your questions for this special series. Use the hashtag ScienceSays and let us know your burning Olympic questions.
And subscribe for more awesome science videos!